destroyed homes in a deserted village
close to the front line
families that used to live here left
when this war started almost eight years
ago
only their broken belongings remain
russian bank separatist positions are
just over the horizon
ukrainian army soldiers tell us their
shelter has been repeatedly targeted in
recent days
craters gouged out by separatist
artillery shells are just a few meters
away
27 year old byrne has been at this
dugout for three months the ukrainian
soldier says separatists are using
higher caliber weapons than before
they are targeting infantry in the
dugouts i stood at the entrance and
heard first incoming 10 meters away from
me they shelled along the road we walk
along perhaps tried to hit our
communication lines
the shelling is much more frequent and
concentrated recently
soldiers take us along a trench to their
observation post
this used to be a separatist trench says
this soldier
there are still anti-personnel mines so
be careful where you put your feet if
you don't want to lose one separatist
positions are under 50 meters in that
direction
most of the men here we speak to say
they have very little hope that a
peaceful solution
can be
we stopped to film when suddenly the
whistle of an incoming shell
you see the bushes there says this
soldier well 23 meters from there is a
separatist trench
between us is a minefield
the bunker is small and cramped
26 year old kippish which roughly
translates as chaos started fighting the
separatists
at the beginning of the conflict eight
years ago
i can't understand putin's politics it's
stupid to be afraid of something when
there's no threat i can't remember when
nato has ever been a threat to russia
not since the collapse of the soviet
union and ukraine independence more than
30 years ago
but that's not what russia's leader
thinks
vladimir putin's vision of the future
remains unclear
charles stratford al-jazeera eastern
ukraine